you were born for this moment please do
your job please smell i think i started
melting from that drew hi everyone my
name is atom bernath and today i'm in
the kitchen with nikki and brian from 88
rising welcome to the kitchen
thank you thank you so much i'm super
excited to be here
nikki and brian have an awesome song now
called california
and on the theme of california since
drew also has california roots
today we'll be making a california
classic everyone loves in-n-out burgers
so today i'm showing you how to make it
in drew's
beautiful air fryer no pun intended it's
not only beautiful to look at but the
company is also called beautiful
let's just jump right into it we're
going to start off by making our burgers
so we have our ground protein here you
can use plant-based protein you can use
beef
and what you just want to do is if you
have some gloves you can put them on and
we're just going to form them into
patties and the trick is if you want to
form them into a patty
about the size of your bun so the buns i
have over here kind of like slider size
so i'm going to do
four kind of two to three inch slider
burgers
got it now do you guys cook often
yes what is your favorite type of food i
love all kinds of asian food
yeah asian food is just awesome i love
asian food but asian food has you know a
lot of like spices so
in the days that i don't have access to
those spices or like you know
don't have time to go to the grocery
store to get all of them i i make steaks
i love like spam all the spam and rice
it's great wait question so are we
smashed
like are we flattening the patties yeah
you can flatten them somewhat because
we're air frying them we're not going to
exactly do a smash burger because
there's enough room in there
got it and they should be the diameter
of
the bun is what you said right there you
go that is the trick they can be a
little bigger but you know around that
size it's a good guide
[Music]
you ever done salt bay action that thing
yes saute all over the top yeah a little
bit of salt by action and
some freshly cracked pepper and then you
literally can just grab your burgers and
place them
straight into the air fryer and
drew's airfryer i drew semi a few weeks
ago and i have been using it and i am
quite a fan i must say are we salting
and peppering
both sides yes i haven't thank you for
calling me out i only did one i will do
the other as we speak
and also while you guys are finishing
forming those just to run through
i made some caramelized onions over here
you guys have them as well
and all this is is you want to melt some
butter a little bit of oil in a pan
and you're just going to low and slow
cook your
sau your onions until they get nice and
caramelized they're going to become nice
and sweet
really bring out a lot of flavor and you
don't want to skip this step
they are really what gives the burger a
lot of delicious sweetness and flavor
now while that is cooking it is time to
make the famous
sauce are you ready for it so let's grab
our chopped up pickles
our ketchup our mayo our mustard very
basic sauce
so basically we're gonna add the ketchup
the mayo the mustard and the pickles
into a bowl now meanwhile
let's talk a little bit about your new
song california
as i said i was jamming out to it in the
kitchen we were watching
your music video and i must say i can
use a little bit of your swag
over here i'm a fan so i'd love to hear
a little bit about like the inspiration
for the song
thank you uh yeah yeah very sweet of you
yeah
it was really cool because it was like a
pandemic kind of like
idea and we all worked on it remotely
like
because usually we would like you know
convene in a studio or whatever you want
to mix that we all kind of like wrote
our own verses
our own courses and then at the end we
just sent it
to each other like over like text or
whatever yeah and then we're like
everybody was like cool i think it's
cool because like we all wrote it
separately but at the same time we like
kind of talked about the same
thing uh same same feeling same
struggles
we kind of just wanted to cover kind of
like our experiences we're all
indonesian on the song
yeah he's in indonesia but not in real
life
so we wanted to kind of cover what it
was like you know moving from jakarta to
l.a yeah and that's kind of what the
song is about little spoiler alert
whenever you go to a restaurant they
have a little pack of special sauce
uh it's really just mayo ketchup mustard
and pickles and that's that's the secret
to the special sauce
so cool interesting the animal style i
have one minute left should i open it up
oh no
give it it's a minute but let me just
kind of show you what's going on over
here
so all you're going to do is you're just
going to now give your burgers a little
flip now
mine smells incredible the airfryer like
i wish you could see
um up closer you guys can see up close
it is super duper
juicy and what's great about the
airfryer is you don't need any fat you
don't need to add any oil into there and
now i'm going to just cook it
for another five minutes bam
bam basically what an air fryer is is
when you think about when you're frying
food in a deep fryer
the whole point is the oil is really hot
you put it in the entire surface area is
covered in the hot oil and gets cooked
so fried the air fryer is basically like
a
super intense convection oven so it's
based like a little oven
with a massive fan that blows around the
air like crazy in there this heats from
every single direction so just like a
deep fryer where you coat the whole
food in the oil that's hot this coats
the food in like really intense air
that's hot and that's kind of how you
mimic the
that's amazing yeah our burgers are
almost done cooking
so why don't we start doing a little bit
of assembly over here
so do you guys have your buns yes yes
my buns are toasted but you can do
toasted or not toasted i think for now
we'll do
not toasted either way uh is definitely
delicious so no worries
in terms of order um you can just kind
of
go however you like i like to start on
the bottom with a little bit of the
special sauce we made
because honestly i like to go special
sauce on the bottom and special sauce on
top i feel like the more special sauce
the better
good i think if you eat a burger and
you're not a mess
after you eat it then it was not a good
burger like you should have the burger
juice dripping down your arms
you're all over your face a clean burger
is a bad burger
right 100 absolutely all right now while
you guys are doing that my burgers are
now out of here mine are done but
um i'm using plant-based meat so my
burgers are going to cook a little
faster than your burgers
so once yours are out i would just take
a peek and they might not be done
but um you can get a little bit more
time but meanwhile regardless
you can then take each one can have a
nice little slice of tomato on the
bottom
and then just to show you what you're
going to do the second they come out of
here you're going to place your burgers
on top of the tomatoes and you're going
to immediately
place your slice of american cheese on
there so that you can use the heat
from the burgers to melt the cheese so
it's kind of a quick
a little bit a little bit of pressure
over here as if we're in our own real in
and out kitchen and there's tons of
customers ordering
so plop that on there pop them on there
seriously i've been slacking i gotta i
gotta do this fast
you gotta focus ryan we need to focus on
here okay
so you're letting us down ryan
[Music]
tomato come on nikki okay okay i just i
absolutely deserve that my burgers have
turned very round
mine are like meatballs as well okay so
i'm gonna put the american cheese over
american cheese over the burgers
right white so your burgers look good on
top of
the tomato i think this is my first time
like
assembling an actual real american
burger do you guys have your caramelized
onions
yes we do this right here perfect now
this is where i would go with a heavy
hand i personally love
a lot of caramelized onions so just pile
them on top
of the cheese is it like a cardinal sin
to put your caramelized onions
on the other bun i would forgive you but
i would put it on the cheese
i would say just grab two pickles per
burger
and then we have some shredded lettuce
over here
that we're just going to finally top
with all right i think it's the moment
of truth
oh my gosh i am i'm i'm actually nervous
ready for it you're gonna take the
bottom bun take the top bun
place it on there and you have made your
first
american oh yours your sources
wow my first like burger you want to see
my favorite burger eating technique
alright ready so you don't make a mess
on yourself step back
like this all right and you go like this
okay
lean over and then take a bite you ready
and cheers
[Music]
lots of chewing sounds that's good
that's
delectable that's good you know you know
that is amazing wow that's really good
um some some well done friends i would
say some would say this is beautiful
drew would probably say that if she was
here yeah i didn't know you can make
burgers with
airfryer but that's yeah really cool i
had no idea that's amazing
with the magic of drew's beautiful
airfryer well if you at home
want to make this recipe you can find
this recipe and more on the
truebarrymore show.com
thank you guys so much for cooking with
me today come to head in the clouds
our festival november 6th and 7th yes
and if you want to follow me you can
follow me at
aton on instagram tiktok and youtube
eitan and
if you need us we will be eating the
rest of our burgers over here with our
little beautiful
airfryer um highly recommend thank you
drew and
drew if you ever want to cook with us
these as well let us know we are
available
thank you guys for watching all right
thank you drew barrymore
thank you drew barrymore